can I trust you
of course
[Music]
always
eight years ago you two were citadel's
top spies but we were double crossed by
one of our own and your memories were
erased
I brought you here because I need your
help I coached Little League
there's my guy
right now every agent around the world
is looking for YouTube
I think you have the wrong person
even though I wish I was dead
[Music]
you remember I
for everything it was Mason case Mason
Kane is dead whoever betrayed us is
readying for something cataclysmic
are we together I'm flatter yourself
Deborah
I'm exceptionally skilled at getting
Citadel agents to turn
[Music]
Mason can never find out he told me to
trust you why would you trust me I'm
exceedingly untrustworthy I'm a spy we
were set up and there's no one else it's
just you and me
is a lie
[Music]